[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning it's
that time again time to bring you some
of the stories that are the talk of the
table this morning and
tony is up first uh okay i'm gonna say
some things about aliens
[Laughter]
you got me already now people who
already believe in aliens are going to
know these things so this is for people
who don't yet believe and maybe they'll
consider it after hearing what i have to
say so an american airlines pilot
saw something mysterious recently during
a flight from cincinnati to phoenix this
was just on sunday
a scanner picked up the pilot's radio
call listen
have any targets up here we just had
something go right over the top of us
that
i hate to say this looked like a long
cylindrical object it almost looked like
a cruise missile type of thing
moving really fast i went right over the
top of us now
american airlines has confirmed that
radio transmission
uh pilots in this country are not known
to see things you know they see pretty
well
uh and this comes uh just a year after
the pentagon
released three videos of unidentified
flying objects you may know them as ufos
recorded by navy fighter pilots it also
comes
in the same year as an astronomer at
harvard named avi loeb
says affirmatively aliens have visited
it's not kidding
maybe maybe it's some martians upset
that we're spending all that time on
their planet
it could be i mean but that but the the
fact we're spending billions to search
for alien life i mean nasa also believes
there is a chance
and some people say it's already
happened i think people see stuff